I had dreams last night on white people
but this doesn't count though because
I'm not threatened by this [ __ ] guy
you should be nice no it's not Bryce
it's a it's a masculine version of Bryce
Oh oysters are aphrodisiacs right yes I
had sex dreams all night that's why yeah
and who was it I need to tell me what oh
yeah I I me and Anderson Cooper were
just totally just yeah yeah I had the
same dream but with Kathy Griffin no but
Anderson Cooper like I've always had a
deep crush on him I would get like
gender reassignment surgery to have sex
with Anderson Cooper that's wrong yeah I
love Cooper I would suck the [ __ ] out of
his limp dick I love Anderson Cooper you
know what I would probably suck Rachel
Maddow's [ __ ] would you have to suck it
there's a lot of liquid in there liquid
she's high along yeah she's right I
really like her a lot but she's too -
left right a little too left for me to
suck her [ __ ] no just in general
nothing nothing someone told me I don't
know if this is real or not but someone
told me that you know how they have
professional cuddlers mm that apparently
they have like professional dry humpers
and I really want to try but I don't
want you to be angry I if you can get a
cell phone you can you can get a
professional dry hump yeah you have
number one yeah I'm there I have to be
there gonna ruin my god that's so the
point is the escape of looking at
someone else forget that then I get to
pick the guy oh no [ __ ] you're gonna
give me
[Laughter]
and he doesn't commit barely does it
yeah yeah oh my god
I didn't say this right now I'm not
telling I'm not there's not a lie if
George dry-hump kalila I would probably
die from laughter you do so okay not all
you I would literally die from laughter
like I would go into convulsions my eyes
would go I would like be it's possessed
by the devil like I would just be like
just constantly just vibrating laughing
yeah it would be out from all the tears
coming out of my eyes I would die from
like wait okay so when people dry hump
do they do they get down to their
underwear or is it with jeans I won't
you go [ __ ] with this [ __ ] naked that's
the sex appeal you grow more jeans but I
want him naked you wear jeans and a
little armor oh my god I could chastity
like a chastity belt
yeah are my titties out I'm sorry I know
that I know women probably find you
attractive and I love you like a brother
but I just find you I just find you so
humorous to me thank you
yeah but not in a good way I find you to
be like my [ __ ] gesture did gesture
yeah but I enjoy you and I'm glad that
we met I'm glad that we have a cosmic
connection you and I yeah yeah you um
you deserve an apology from me yeah yeah
when I first met him I didn't like this
guy he grew on me yo he dead he grew on
me and I literally at nights pray to God
thanking them thanking god damn all the
gods all the gods yeah that they put you
in my life oh just suffer all the laughs
and I really all the laughs the guy when
I just
look at your [ __ ] face I love it
thank you and I apologize I do what you
got a problem no no no
if you ever [ __ ] look at me go are
you gonna go on that audition right I
swear to [ __ ] god you could die next
time which one
why are you threatened you have a real
name you are so competitive with me how
we're not in the same [ __ ]
competitive OPEC competitive last year
you did the same thing dude okay you
[ __ ] book the head I mean this piece
of [ __ ] yeah we're not well you said I
want you to make you're gonna make it
alright but don't be competitive with me
okay just touch your butt yeah you thank
you go ahead I want to say this alright
of course I'm gonna go out on that
[ __ ] audition okay I just what my
response to you is always out of
nervousness you know when I get this
email like it says NBC all that stuff
and you know are you you know and I see
this letter and I have to you know I get
nervous
the reason I'm relaying this information
to you is because your manager is out of
town we go until Sunday and she says
kalila you know take care of everything
this week so my job was emails and say
hey Bobby but that's not until next week
right we don't have the date set well
I'm not doing it this week because I
leave Thursday right Bobby what I'm
saying is the only reason I didn't mean
to stress you out I just have to let you
know of certain things on your schedule
this week or else I'm letting her down
mm-hmm it's just for you to be happy
it's not to disrupt your day
[Music]